here are three books that you must read
if you want to get good at marketing and
sales
one The Ultimate Sales Machine by Chet
Holmes this book is a comprehensive
guide to sales covering everything from
lead generation and closing deals to
managing a sales team
2. influence the psychology of
persuasion by Robert seal deeney this
book explores the psychology of
influence and how to use it to become
more persuasive in sales and marketing
3. contagious why things catch on by
Jonah Berger this book explores the
science behind why some ideas and
products go viral While others do not
and how to create contagious content for
your business
thank you for watching And subscribe for
more